so with young adult fiction is one of
the tests that it should be enjoyable to
adults but if it's not then maybe a
young adult readership would be bored
because it's not sophisticated enough
that's a really great question i would
say that kids tend to read up which
means that you know whatever the age
range that we specify for these books i
find may tend to read up like i was
reading stephen king and a nice when I
was in Middle School in high school but
I probably started out reading things
like Judy Blume and things that skewed a
little bit younger so yeah I think it
does need to have a certain level of
sophistication to hold a teen audience
now if excused too old I mean my books
are considered more crossover for some
of the reasons I was talking about that
I have some adult points of view that it
is a third-person multiple point of view
story so when I was originally trying to
sell it we got a lot of feedback like
this is crossed over we don't know how
to market it and I was like isn't that a
good problem like wooden isn't it better
if it appeals to both teens and adults
but so the publishing industry I think
has been a little slow to catch up to
this idea that a lot of adults are
reading young adult and that T meters
you tend to read up I think they're a
little behind and understanding that but
I think that it's a real benefit if the
book is a little more sophisticated if
it is appealing both to teens and adults
but yeah I think you need to keep their
attention another thing I think is
important which we've really tried to do
with my series is to put the books out
in a relatively quick time frame because
also readers they will grow out of
reading something so if you have
multiple years between books coming out
I think you're doing yourself a
disservice because you know by the time
the second book comes out there already
in college right and then the third book
who knows so we're trying to do six
months apart on my trilogy because I
think that makes a lot of sense is there
a focus group that you're running the
let's say semi edited version through oh
I don't really have a focus group I mean
I think that when you first start
writing a lot of authors have critique
partners which are really important to
the process which would be trusted
readers that you trust to give feedback
on your man you
I have another author that my trade
books with and he writes stuff totally
different for me it's a typically these
days it's a nonfiction world war two
Nazi books you know so they're totally
different but he's really smart and we
trade reads now that I have a publishing
deal and I have a big agent team I don't
do that as much and I don't really have
the time so my team is the people who
are reading and giving feedback or my
agent and my editors at my publishing
house so and it read this point I'm
really tailoring the books to them
because that who's really going to be
distributing my book and then i'm also
at this point trying to keep a
consistency in the story and I kind of
know where I am and how I'm writing it
tomm not at a place where I need
feedback so much on how I'm writing if
that makes sense in the beginning a lot
of it is trying to improve your craft
I'm at a point now where I'm just trying
to tell the best stories that I can
because I you know I already have a
style that I've developed in terms of
how i right so but I am looking forward
to getting back to writing something
different and new and i'm sure i'll be
using critique partners on that once i
start writing my next book